I'm really passionate about climate change.
I'm worried that there won't be enough fresh water for everybody.
I wanna make sure that we're able to have a self-sustaining environment.
My interest is to find a cure for breast cancer because my mom had it.
The cracks are probably where the water is.
Seeing stuff like this...
And I think, I wanna be able to help do that.
It makes me feel like, unstoppable.
That makes no sense to me.
Like, why would that be?
There is always going to be someone that says like, "No, you can't do it."
I think I can.
We're as amazing as men.
Like, we can do as much stuff as they can.
I want my name to be there and be like,...
...."Marley was the one who helped stop this climate change issue."
I will discover a cure for breast cancer.
We need all hands on deck right now.